in watching al-jazeera reminder of our
top story this hour the Supreme Leader
of Iran Ayatollah Syed Ali Khamenei says
those who killed Qasem Soleimani should
away quote tough revenge Iranians are
mourning the death of sulemani at Friday
prayers in Tehran after authorizing the
strike president Donald Trump tweeted a
picture of the American flag but he's
made no further comment yet Qasem
Soleimani s death has exacerbated
already tense relations between Iran and
the United States well we're gonna bring
in our guest who is with me here in the
studio Marwan Beshara who is our senior
political analyst and he joins us here
in the studio now Marwan I was very
struck earlier listening to Dorsett
Jabari we were looking at those pictures
of Friday prayers earlier and she talked
of what she described as a great sense
of betrayal in Tehran now if you were
potentially looking at this from the US
perspective you're thinking betrayal why
what does that mean I just wonder if you
can unpack that for us well I mean
certainly the United States and Iran go
through a long process of negotiations
over a nuclear agreement by which the
United States was going to basically
lift sanctions and allow Iran to develop
peacefully of course free of nuclear
programs and weapons and so forth the
advent of the trump administration
changed all of that and suddenly these
sanctions were imposed primary section
secondary sanctions attempt to [ __ ]
the Iranian regime until it comes back
humiliated to the negotiations table in
order to renegotiate the deal
and clearly president Trump has been
quite aggressive in his approach to to
Iran and at this point in time the only
way I can see and I interpret the the
killing of Qasem Soleimani
is a declaration of war because this was
not done covertly this was not done in
secret and certainly this was not done
and no responsibilities
recognized the Trump has boosted
basically of killing the Iranian
commander and that for me again it's
very similar to some sort of sort of a
middle-aged challenge to a duel so
basically what we have now and and I ask
all our viewers to forget about
everything else all the noise and all
the other ayatollahs and all the
advisers and and even the president like
president rouhani and foreign minister
Zarif all of that now is noise
what we have is president from
challenging ally hominid to a duel let's
fight it out basically and does that
have to end in all-out escalation
because both sides potentially have a
lot to lose absolutely so the question
is and here I have a number of I would
say out-of-the-box ideas about what the
Trump administration might be thinking
just to follow their or president
Trump's logic over the last three years
so I'm gonna ask a provocative question
I'm ready
is President Trump planning to withdraw
America from Iraq like he did from Syria
like he is trying to do in Afghanistan
is President Trump in the mindset that
look we don't need all this headache in
the various countries on the hotspots of
the Middle East we need to bring our
troops home but our Navy our Marines and
our Air Force will stay there and if
anyone moves in any which way against
our embassies or against our interests
we will attack them but we don't have to
be held hostage our our people our
experts our teachers and so on so forth
in the various hot spots of the Middle
East so this could be a sophisticated
strategy from the US administration with
pre-planning as opposed to you know the
initial statements that we had from the
US whether this was you know a
provocative action or reflect something
that looked like it might have been done
on the hoof and also I remember just
earlier this week I think it was New
Year's Eve we heard Trump say at an
event Melania was standing next to him
and he said you know we don't want ask
Asian man actually Iran shouldn't want
escalation either and yet here we are
so please I mean don't I mean don't use
big words like sophistication because I
you know the only thing to be expected
from this administration has been not to
expect much from this administration
because you never know what happens next
but clearly this kind of an action after
saying we don't want war from Iran to
basically declare war against Iran by
attacking its one of its you know heroes
among its commanders the closest man
probably to Ayatollah Khomeini the sword
of Ayatollah how many over the last two
decades and then to say I don't want
world war forever and I want trouble
with Iran is of course you know runs
shallow in so many ways but once again
the scenarios could differ because
history of the last 40 years teaches us
that Iran is not interested in fighting
the United States on its own field in
its own landscape of power which is
direct military confrontation because
everyone knows and no Iranian should
have a second thought that Iran will be
crushed if it's going to fight the
United States face-to-face
military-to-military and that's why the
Iran for the last 40 years has avoided
it's called a good force it's supposed
to liberate all codes meaning Jerusalem
and yet there has been no confrontation
between Iran and Israel for the last 40
years no direct confrontation between
Iran and Israel while we have this
commander former commander in a late
commander who was tasked by Alf codes
force so he won is not about to do what
it has avoided doing for the last 40
years which is military confrontations
with military powers that are superior
to it militarily hence that takes us to
other forms of confrontation could it be
covert operation could be systematic
long process of assassinations against
America and its allies and so forth
could it will be proxy meeting using its
assets in Iraq Syria Lebanon and
elsewhere or could it be some form of an
escalation in the Gulf region for
example that will allow once again to of
course the hiking of the oil prices of
the peace and security the international
peace is still to be put at risk there
are a number of scenarios out there
we'll leave it there for just now thank
you